- Hello, and welcome to "Ed
Talks" with Khan Academy.
I am excited today to be
talking to Fenesha Hubbard
who is with NWEA, one of
our partner organizations
that we'll talk more about in a minute,
and she is the professional
learning design coordinator.
So I'm excited to talk to her
about professional learning for teachers.
Before we get started, I
want to remind everyone
that Khan Academy is a
non-profit organization,
and we are able to do our work
through donations from people like you.
If you go to khanacademy.org/donate,
you will find a way that you can help us
continue this work through your donations.
Thank you.
I also want to recognize
some of our sponsors
who really helped support us
through the COVID-19 crisis,
and that includes Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis,
Fastly, and General Motors.
Thank you.
And finally, if you have missed
some other "Ed Talks" and "Homerooms,"
you can find us, audio
versions of those talks,
on your favorite podcast provider
at looking for "Homeroom with Sal,"
and you can listen to Sal
and I interview other folks
who are influencers in
the education world.
And with that, let me welcome Fenesha.
Fenesha, welcome, thanks for joining us.
- Hi, Kristen, thank you
so much for having me.
- Absolutely.
So first, let me just give
a quick background for folks
on who is NWEA?
So NWEA, as I said, is one
of our partner organizations
and they're a nonprofit that
supports students and educators
in more than 146 countries
doing research, assessment solutions,
policy and advocacy services,
professional learning,
and school improvement services.
And I know that that core to NWEA's work
is really fighting for equity driving,
impacting classrooms, and
pushing for systemic change
in our education communities.
So, that is a big bunch
of work to bite off.
Tell me what your role is.
- Kristen, I love being at NWEA.
I've been at NWEA for about 10 years
and what I do is really support
our educators nationwide.
And I do that by designing
the professional learning
that teachers need to stay
on top of their craft.
I really enjoy the work.
- That is awesome.
How did you get into that?
How did you get to be in this
role of supporting teachers?
- I think to support teachers in this way,
you had to have been a teacher,
so that's how I started my career.
I started teaching middle school math
in a very large school district,
and it was through an
alternative certification program
for career changers.
So these were people who
had established careers,
and they said, "You know what?
I really wanna support students."
And so I started off doing that
and then was very quickly immersed
into the world of professional learning.
And so I started designing
learning for teachers,
coaching teachers in math,
and that led me to where I am today.
- That is awesome.
So, I mentioned that one of
the things that NWEA does
is research and understanding
more about student learning,
and I know you've just released a report
on learning during COVID.
What were the kinds of questions
you were investigating?
- Yeah, great question.
Our research team, Kristen,
really wanted to see
how students were fairing
during the pandemic.
That was our main focus.
And what we noticed is that
if we focus on the good,
gains were made, right?
These were a very challenging two years,
but gains were made.
However, students showed
a lower performance
compared to the past trends.
And when we think about math education,
there were declines in math
across all the grades and all the groups.
So we think about,
but you have a nice visual there,
the largest declines in math, Kristen,
were among students of color
and students in high poverty schools.
And so I think one of the biggest things
we should do right now
is probably talk about,
what are we gonna do about it?
- Absolutely.
I liked the positive bit
that people did learn
something over the pandemic,
but didn't get as far
as we would have liked them to get likely.
So, let's start with parents
and thinking about parents first.
What can parents do to support
students in learning math?
- That is the question,
particularly because so
many of our young people
spent good quality time with their parents
these past couple years.
So I know that question
was coming up repeatedly.
As a parent, how can I support my child?
What do I need to do?
I think, Kristen, what we
really wanna encourage parents
to do is get their students
talking about math.
We wanna help young people
get their thoughts out of their heads
and let it come out and come through
in the best way that students can do that.
I think we can actually learn
a lot from our young people
in the sense that students
always ask, why, "Why?
Why does this work?
Why do I do it that way?"
I think as parents, we
need to do that same thing.
Start asking why a lot
more of our students,
particularly when they come
to us and they might say,
"Hey, can you help me work
through this problem?"
Or, "I don't understand."
Throw that question out there.
Well, why would you do this?
And why does this work?
And why do you think that?
And I think that helps
us to really get insight
into how students are thinking about math
and the ways that they think about it.
- That makes sense.
I've heard friends who are parents
worry about what do they do
if they don't know the answer,
if they don't know how
to do a math problem
that their child brings to them.
Any suggestions for that?
- I think Khan Academy
is a great suggestion.
(Kristen laughing)
- I wasn't trying to lead you there.
(both women laughing)
- I think before we start
seeking external resources,
like Khan Academy is a
great external resource,
but I think really having the students
step into the position
of an empowered learner
with their parents is going to be key.
So empowered learner,
meaning, you know what,
I do bring something to the table.
I do have something that I
understand about the content,
but I also have a stumbling block.
And so if I can come to the table
and start talking through my
misconceptions as a parent,
what you can do is just
help guide my thinking,
help pull it out of me.
You don't need to know all
of the content to do that.
You just need to know how
to ask really good questions
and how to read me as your child
and understand my body language
and the things that I
might be stumbling on
and the things that I'm confident about.
- That makes sense, and I
know there's good research
to support that using the language of math
and just talking about math
as being really important
in learning outcomes, so
that totally makes sense.
It's about having the
conversation sometimes
instead of having to find
the right answer right away.
That rings true.
- That's right.
- All right, so what about teachers?
We've gotten this idea of
these maybe learning gaps
that have opened up where students
aren't where they might
have been in the past
coming into the new year.
What should teachers be thinking about
to address some of that?
- Hmm, that's a really good question, too.
I think, one, we should
all come to an agreement
that there was a lot
of interrupted learning
that took place, and I
think once people are okay
with admitting that, you know what,
there were some breaks in the
routines and how we learned.
And because of that interrupted learning,
students might have some
unfinished learning,
and the unfinished learning
are like the skills
and the prerequisite knowledge
that students might need
in order to be ready to
learn what's coming next.
And so I think teachers are
well-positioned right now
to really assess what unfinished learning
students might have.
And they can do that through
the use of assessments.
The data can tell us what
students might be ready to learn,
what they might have already mastered,
and we can do that through actual tests,
and we can also do that
through formative assessment,
which is something that teachers
do so skillfully every day.
And that's informal ways to get data,
to inform instruction
right on the spot realtime.
- What are some of your favorites
of those kind of more informal things
that teachers do to start to understand
where students are, what their skills are?
- Ooh, that's a great question.
I love math language routines,
and so I think about a
math language routine
of the problem with
three reads, for example.
So, we're working on a math problem.
I'm simply gonna start off
by asking you to read the problem
and then I'm gonna ask you,
"What is this problem asking us about?"
So in simply asking that question,
I'm getting an understanding
of how my students are interpreting that.
And then we might read the question again,
and then I'll say, "Okay, well,
what information do we need
in order to solve this problem?"
So that gives me insight
into the student's level of readiness
in terms of background
knowledge that they might need.
And so it's really helping
me to unpack the context
and the purpose from my
students' understanding.
Teachers are generally very well skilled
at the strategies that we might use.
Another thing we might do are
entrance and exit tickets.
- Wait, I think you said three reads.
Is there a third read?
Did I hear the third read?
- Oh, hold on, okay, let's go back.
So the three reads.
- Let's go back.
- So the first one, read the problem.
And then I say, "Okay, what
is this problem about?"
And then you're telling me
what you think the problem is about.
I'm not confirming or affirming.
I just wanna know.
The second read, now I ask you,
"What are we trying to find out?"
So a little different there.
You know what, parents can use it, too.
So, parents, I hope you're taking note.
What are we trying to find out?
And then we read the problem again,
and now I'm gonna ask you,
"What information might
be useful to solve this?"
So in knowing information,
now we're starting to get at
what the math is behind that.
- That makes sense, yes, yes.
Man, that sounds like the teacher
would get a lot of information
about what the student
knows and what they can do
and all of those from
that kind of interaction.
Great.
- Definitely.
I think the intent is to really get behind
what students are thinking.
How are you thinking about the math?
And that helps me to understand
what you know about the math
and what misconceptions you might have.
- Yeah, yeah.
What do you see as the biggest
challenges teachers face
in teaching math,
and maybe it's different
for elementary students
versus teachers of older students,
but just what are some
of the big challenges?
- I think the challenge that we face
since like time immemorial
is it's been illuminated and
heightened during the pandemic,
And that's the challenge
of how do I meet the needs
of so many different levels
of readiness in my classroom?
If I teach seventh grade math,
but I have students who
are academically ready
for content maybe at
the fifth grade level,
or I have students who might be ready
to be challenged a little
more at the ninth grade level,
as a seventh grade math teacher,
the challenge for me
then becomes making sure
I have a good depth and breadth
of understanding of the content
and that I can really
scaffold my instruction
for my students, no matter where they are.
That is a huge challenge
that was heightened
during the pandemic.
And when I say scaffolding,
that's literally thinking
about how you might build structures
to help students grow from
where they are in the learning.
Does that make sense, Kristen?
- Yeah, it does, it does.
And so now if we have students
where there's even more variability
throughout the class
of where students are,
we've got even more levels
that teachers are trying to address.
What are some of the things they can do
if they have students who
are at seven different levels
in what they're trying to learn?
- I think we want to
first encourage teachers
to stay grounded in what the expectation
and the standard is for the students.
Because if you immediately,
and I'm only saying this from a teacher
who has the experience.
I've taught in a classroom
where you have students
who their literacy level is
pretty much non-existent,
versus students who just
needs to be challenged
and sent to higher level math.
I have been there, okay,
so I understand the immediate reactions
to first go to like
the reality of the fact
that I have to cover so much content
with all of these students.
And I think if we start at that point,
it feels too overwhelming.
It can feel pretty daunting.
That's a daunting task.
So I think it's important
for our teachers to really get clear on
what is it that my students need to know,
what's the grade level standard,
and what are the expectations
that I personally hold for my students?
I had just mentioned the interrupted
and unfinished learning.
Sometimes, Kristen, when we have a lot
of interrupted learning,
it can lead to assumptions.
Meaning I can very easily assume
that my students don't
know A, B, or C content
simply because of the fact
that they missed so much.
And I think when we have
assumptions like that,
I have a colleague, Chase Nordengren,
and he always says that
assumptions are a threat to equity.
And I think in this case,
assumptions could be a threat to equity
because then it could
start to limit the content
that our students are exposed to.
And ultimately what we wanna do
is make sure that we're
exposing our students
to grade level content
irregardless of where their
readiness level might be.
And the challenge then for
teachers is how to do that.
That's the biggest challenge.
That was a challenge I faced
throughout my entire career,
is helping people understand,
how do I keep my students engaged
at levels that honor where they are,
but still hold the standard or expectation
for their grade level?
And I think that is a matter
of really getting clear on the content.
So let's break it, make it real.
If I'm a student who
really is still struggling
with my multiplication facts,
for the life of me, I cannot tell you
what seven times six is, that
trips me up every single time.
That should not stop me
from then being able to
learn about measurement
in terms of area and volume.
Now the job becomes for my teachers,
how do I still teach
this higher level concept
while still throwing in opportunities
for me to practice my facts?
That's a daily challenge
that teachers face,
so we wanna make sure that
we still expose students
to that higher level standard
that we want them to be at.
Another challenge for teachers then
is to really understand their
content across grade levels.
So we think about, yes, if
I teach seventh grade math,
I have to be a master at that,
but I also need to understand
third, fourth, and fifth grade math,
and sixth grade, and then eighth, ninth,
and 10th grade math,
because there are some
concepts that you teach
where you absolutely have to
know the prerequisite skills.
You have to know them.
And so now my job then as a teacher
is to figure out how
do I weave that knowing
into the lessons?
Is that making sense, Kristen?
- It absolutely does,
and I think that point about
having both the exposure
to grade level skills
and the ability to start to
practice those prerequisites
that are really necessary to be successful
on those grade level skills
is such a difficult balance.
There's only so many
hours in a day (laughing)
of where students get.
And for a teacher, I can imagine,
do teachers need to basically prepare
lots of different lessons?
Or how do they think about
preparing say that area unit?
And they know they have some students
that struggle with multiplication,
but they have some students
who maybe already understand
volume and increase.
How do they go about just the preparation
for teaching that area standard?
- I feel overwhelmed just
hearing that question,
because if I were a teacher
and thought that I had to then plan
a bunch of different lessons
to meet the needs of all of my students,
I would probably decide
that, you know what,
I probably need a break from teaching.
We don't wanna take that perspective
of needing to design lessons
that meet the needs of
every single student
in the sense that I'm designing a lesson
for each student group in my class.
That's not the approach we wanna take.
What we wanna do is really
make sure we understand
what the big lesson is
that we're teaching,
and in our lesson design,
build in opportunities
to really have student discourse.
We have to have students talking,
telling how they're thinking.
And the reason you're doing that
is because you're leveraging
your students' funds of
knowledge in the classroom.
You're helping them to support
the instruction of this lesson.
So, what does that mean in layman's terms?
If I have a student in my classroom
who's really struggling
with those basic facts
and that's keeping them from understanding
how we're doing the Pythagorean theorem
and how we're drawing that out,
using triangles to figure it out,
what I wanna do then is make
sure I'm asking questions
that gets that student talking
about what they understand
and then possibly showing their work
and how they're thinking.
And then as a teacher, this
gives me an opportunity now
to maybe take how my students are thinking
and start to tell a story, right?
So, if I'm engaging in a lesson
and I know that I'm gonna
have a group of students
who are gonna get it right away,
I'm not gonna start off by
using their work as an exemplar.
I wanna tell a story
that builds on the math,
such that I'm starting with
the student who is missing,
they might have greater
misconceptions, right?
And then I'm gonna build on that
and I'm gonna draw in
another student's sample work
where they have a greater understanding.
And in building that story,
then students can start to
have a better understanding
of the concepts.
So that's a very long-winded way of saying
we're not designing lessons.
You're not taking one lesson
and designing like 30 other
mini lessons to go with it.
What you're doing is
building opportunities
in the lesson that you're designing
to uncover what students know,
to give everybody an
opportunity to engage,
no matter what they know, right?
So if you are just at the level,
the basic level on this
ladder of instruction
that we're climbing,
then I wanna make sure you have a voice
in this discussion in this lesson.
So I'm building in equitable opportunities
for everyone to participate.
And in doing that, ultimately,
I'm gonna meet my goal
of making sure that all
students are getting access
to that top rung and they're
moving up the ladder.
- That makes sense, that makes sense.
So, both of us work for organizations
that believe that technology
can potentially have a role
in helping to address
this particular problem
of thinking about differentiation
and making sure that students
get the support they need
and access to grade level material.
And we're really happy
with our partnership
that's created something
called MAP Accelerator
to help teachers meet some of those needs.
Can you talk a little bit about
that MAP Accelerator experience
and how it might fit into this?
- Definitely.
I'm really glad that you
mentioned the MAP Accelerator.
So, Khan academy has partnered with NWEA
and we've partnered to
create MAP Accelerator.
The reason behind the
partnership is one, okay,
Khan Academy by itself is a
dynamic and wonderful tool.
When you bring in MAP Growth,
which is our assessment,
MAP Growth is a test that students take,
and the data, their results,
tell us what they're ready to learn.
It tells us what their
level of readiness is.
So, it's not a test of mastery.
It's not saying, all
right, I'm gonna test you
on all the fifth grade skills to see,
have you mastered those?
It's gonna say, you know what,
I'm gonna test you on
a plethora of skills,
and the test is gonna adjust
based on how you answer,
because what I'm trying
to do is figure out,
what's your zone for learning?
What's your zone of proximal development?
And then once I have that information,
it's put into MAP Accelerator,
and then MAP Accelerator designs
or it creates a learning
path for me as a student
that grows with me.
So it starts at my zone,
and as I progress through
my zone and I learn more,
it moves with me.
So it's just a wonderful,
powerful tool that we have
to really support teachers
and the wide variety of student
readiness in our classroom.
- So we've got teachers
doing all the great things
that you described with those activities
that are accessible for
students who have skill gaps,
but also challenge other
students and all of that.
And then paired with
that, we have this tool
that when students are
working individually
can help really target where they are
based on those MAP Growth scores
and help bring those together.
So, that seems like a good balance.
How do you see technology
fitting into classrooms?
- That is the key question.
Now we have to put this
all in context, Kristen.
We have to keep in mind that
our students have engaged
with technology over
the past couple of years
in a way that was very different
than how they engaged before, right?
So, we have to be mindful of
the fact that our students,
they feel some type of
way about technology.
They could feel overwhelmed.
They could have gotten
into certain routines.
So what we wanna do is really
empower teachers and students
to have the routines that you wanna employ
from MAP Accelerator.
A routine might be, we've
got 30 minutes a week,
that's our MAP Accelerator time.
That's my Khan Academy time.
And then let's create some
rituals to support that.
And the ritual might be something
like a Talk It Out Tuesday
or a Work It Out Wednesday,
or a Think About It Thursday.
So what we wanna do is
create these rituals
that engage students
and teachers together.
So, we've got the
technology in the center,
but we wanna use our
discourse to bring us together
so that it becomes an
interactive tool for everybody.
So a teacher might say,
"All right, it's Talk It Out Tuesday.
What I want you to do after
your MAP Accelerator time
is go back and find that one problem
that you kept getting stuck doing,
you kept having to hit
the hint function for.
The problem just, hmm, you
had a little struggle with it,
productive struggle.
And what I want you to
do is now talk it out
with a partner in the classroom.
And in the talking it out,
you might gain a little bit more clarity."
Or we could have a Work It Out Wednesday,
where students are encouraged
to go to their caregivers
and show and tell.
Let them see a MAP Accelerator experience
and then work it out with that person.
So that gives the student opportunity
to then step outside of their head,
do their thinking out loud,
and continue working on their path.
So I think, Kristen, what we wanna do
is leverage technology in a way
that's really gonna empower
our students right now,
really being mindful about
the experiences they've had
these past couple of years,
and how do we re-empower them.
- I heard a couple of things.
I heard the peer-to-peer
learning piece going on
and we know that that's powerful.
And then I heard them
explaining to a caregiver
which then puts them where it goes back
to what we were talking
about at the beginning
about using math language
with an adult maybe,
and they can become the expert
and explain how it's done.
I like both of those ideas
where we're not just having a student
sitting in front of a computer
isolated by themselves,
but creating more of a
community around the technology.
- That's right.
We need to have so much more discourse.
That's what's gonna
bring everything alive.
- Yeah, and I feel like
after this past year,
everyone is just really eager
to make those personal
connections with people
that were more difficult when
we were all in quarantine
in the COVID situation.
- That's right.
- So, we talked a bit
about both the past year
and how those students were fairing.
One of the biggest questions we got was,
how do we keep students motivated?
How do we keep them engaged in learning
and what they're doing?
Are there technology tools
that can help keep students engaged?
And what other suggestions
do you have for teachers?
- Yeah, well, one, MAP Accelerator.
So we definitely wanna make sure
that whatever digital
tools that we're using
with our young people,
we're making it something
so that it is a
self-regulated tool for them.
But we have to find ways
to stay engaged with them
and get regular feedback from them
and allow them time to share
with us what they're doing.
So, I think that's one
of the biggest tools
that we need to employ.
I would love to see
teachers supporting students
in goal setting more,
because we all like to experience success.
It feels good.
It's empowers us, right?
It gives us inspiration and motivation
to keep moving forward.
And so, I would love to see teachers
working alongside students to set goals
with their MAP Accelerator,
and then checking in on
those goals regularly,
short-term goals, too.
So, we're not talking about
by the end of the school year,
I want you to be able to do this.
No, I might set a weekly goal,
because I have weekly
MAP Accelerator time,
and that goal could be
around two or three skills.
And I wanna make sure
that's an achievable goal,
it feels achievable,
and it's something that I
can track my own progress on
and I can talk about it and I
can find reasons to celebrate.
- Fenesha, you're speaking my language.
I can't tell you how often (laughing)
I talk about goals and goal setting,
and that is a way to motivate,
because, yeah, we are
motivated when we see success
and when we feel like
we're gonna be successful.
Nothing shows success like past success.
So yeah, goal setting is huge for me,
so I love that we're
connected on that. (chuckling)
So, we're almost already out of time.
We have a couple of questions.
We have a question from Facebook,
from Charles Drayden who has just,
this might be a good one to end on.
I have a young child.
How can I help him flourish
in his math studies?
And I like that question,
that isn't just succeed,
but flourish. (chuckling)
- I love it.
- So, any other tips you have
that we haven't gotten to?
- Well, thank you so
much for that question
and thank you for chiming in on Facebook.
I think it's really important
for parents and caregivers
to find ways to bring math alive
in our students' everyday life.
And sometimes people say,
"I don't even know how I use
math in my everyday life."
Let me tell you one of my favorite books.
It's a book called "Math Curse."
It's a children's book
and it just talks about
how everything is a math problem.
So, a lot of our school students
are starting back in school.
You might have an eighth grader
who doesn't have to wear a
uniform to school every day,
and they have the opportunity
to express themselves.
And you know at that age
it's all about them anyway.
And so, how does that
turn into a math problem?
You could ask them, "How
many different outfits
could you put together
from these four or five
items of clothing?"
That's a math problem.
You might have a second grader
who's totally fascinated by the cicadas.
Well, here in the Midwest,
at least we have cicadas.
It's cicada time.
- I heard, I heard.
- Yes, and at nighttime,
the sound is beautiful.
And so, they might be
so fascinated by cicadas
and grasshoppers and crickets.
How does that turn into a math problem?
I want you to go listen to those insects
and I want you to tell me
who's chirping the fastest.
So now we're talking
about frequency, right?
So, everything becomes a math problem.
So, Charles, what I think
you and other parents can do
is really find ways to make
math come alive in everyday life
because math is fun and it should be fun.
And we have to all be able
to say that learning is fun.
Let's not forget that.
- That seems like a great
note to end this on.
Thank you so much for joining me today.
It was great to hear
your wisdom and ideas,
and I love that you are out
there working with teachers
to better support students for learning.
- Thank you so much, Kristen.
I always enjoy working with Khan Academy.
Thank you for having me.
- Excellent.
Thank you all and we
will see you next time.